we ran on in our commitment to America
that we would work to secure America's
border because since the day Joe Biden
took office
he took very specific actions to open up
America's border day one he halted
construction of the wall he terminated
the remaining Mexico policy ended
agreements with Northern triangle
countries
and Joe Biden sent a message that
America's border is open and millions of
people answered that call and started
coming across our border illegally
we don't know the exact number because
the White House won't tell the American
people how many have come across our
border illegally nor will they tell
the country where all of those people
have gone Governors don't even know how
many people are sent into their states
at dark of night that will be put into
their school systems who knows what else
has happened we do know this many people
on the terrorist watch list have been
caught coming across our Southern border
since Joe Biden opened it up again we've
never been able to find out an exact
number that's something we're working on
but it's something that should concern
all Americans we're not just talking
about people coming from south in
Central America
we've already identified over 140
different countries
that are represented coming across our
border illegally since Joe Biden took
office this is a national crisis it's
creating a lot of other problems too
we see the fentanyl crisis and how bad
it's gotten
last year we lost almost a hundred
thousand young people who died from drug
overdoses
from drugs like fentanyl which are made
in China
pass through the cartels across our open
Southern border every single day in
America near nearly 300 young people die
because of fentanyl overdoses due to Joe
Biden's open Southern border and what
has President Biden's answer been
every day yesterday today 300 young
people will die from drug overdoses from
fentanyl tomorrow another 300 people
will die because of overdoses from drugs
like Fentanyl and yet President Biden
doesn't want to do a thing to change
that because he wants an open Southern
border well I can tell you House
Republicans are fed up and House
Republicans are taking action the
chairman and members behind me have been
hard at work in the Committees of
jurisdiction Judiciary Committee
Homeland Security committee the Foreign
Affairs committee all have taken action
now
over the last few weeks to put together
what I would call the strongest border
security package that Congress has ever
taken up and will return in May
the same week that title 42 expires
we're going to bring a border security
package and pass it through this House
of Representatives and we challenge
President Biden to work with us to solve
this problem we're going to show the
president how to solve the problem
while he's appointed as vice president
to be the borders are and she won't even
acknowledge that this is a problem most
Americans know this as out of control
and the open Southern border has to be
closed and resolved and let's get back
to a working functioning legal
immigration system that we're so far
removed from
I want to applaud the members who have
been hard at work on this we have had
meetings for months now with individual
members with groups of members to work
through all of the complicated issues
and I'm excited to have these chairmen
that have been working on these issues
and then moving those bills through
their committee to address this problem
and I will start with the chairman of
the Judiciary Committee Jim Jordan
so 350 000 unaccompanied children in the
last two years have come into our
country and Joe Biden's Administration
doesn't know where 85 000 of those kids
are that is uh they don't know where
they are and those that they do know
where they are there is no no vetting
process for the homes and the places
these children go to no follow-up other
than a phone call to these places our
bill is designed to stop that I
understand this too as as the leader
mentioned
this is the result of intentional
policies this Administration has has
started from day one as as Steve
mentioned day one they said no more wall
no more remain in Mexico you get to our
country you're going to be released
somewhere into the country so we put
together what we believe is the
strongest immigration enforcement
legislation ever it deals with the
unaccompanied alien children issue I
just talked about it deals with the
Flora situation deals with Asylum
e-verify Parole Authority and of course
the remain in Mexico policy as well as
Visa overstay issues we think it's
a strong bill that will correct the
problem I described and correct the
problems we have seen now the entire two
years of this Administration and I
really want to thank uh as as Steve
mentioned this was a team effort I
really want to thank the members on our
committee Mr McClintock Mr Biggs Mr
Johnson Mr Roy Mr Tiffany Mr Moran Mr
bent and then two individuals not on the
committee Mr Carter Mr Calvert for
sponsoring the elements that became this
piece of legislation which is going to
get combined I believe with the good
work that Mr Green has done in his
committee and the bill they passed uh I
guess this morning out of their
committee uh and Mr McCall whose bill
passed yesterday's as as well so
um that's what we're going to happen
we're going to be on the floor as the
leader mentioned in a couple weeks and
take that first step into getting
control of our border that hasn't been
under control at all for this
Administration but that'll yield to the
chairman of the homeland security
committee
in 2020
the nation saw about half just under
half a million people come into the
country
in 2021 almost 2 million
four times the year prior
if you look at the last two years of the
Biden Administration and add all the
numbers up the 5 million encounters the
1.4 million gotaways you put it all
together we're talking six well over six
million people
more by the way than many states
population like 25 State populations by
the way
it's greater than all of the folks who
came in under President Obama and
president Trump 12 years combined in
just two years what happened
well we didn't cut the budget
we didn't suddenly decrease the size
accustomed to border patrol
what Joe Biden and Alejandro mayarkas
did is they did away with 89 policies of
previous presidents that was the
difference
they allowed the return agreements with
other countries to completely expire so
that ice has no way to send people back
home the agreements have expired
that this was intentional
and when when I got the gavel we came in
we took a bunch to the border with boot
camp and we we had a hearing on the
border where we learned that secretary
our chief Ortiz admitted that secretary
mayorkas's statement that we had
operational control of the Southern
border was a lie and we do not have in
fact he went on to say five of our nine
sectors of our Southwest border are
under the control of the drug cartels
that's the chief of the Border Patrol
these decisions made by Joe Biden and
Alejandro mayarkas have facilitated the
drug cartels using the strategy of
overwhelming The Crossing sites tying up
Customs and Border Patrol and then
sliding the drugs around them in the
thinned out rural areas and when Merrick
Garland agreed to that in front of the
Senate
the secretary secretary marioquez was
asked did you do you know about this
strategy
and secretary mayorka said no I I didn't
know any the Secretary of Homeland
Security doesn't know the major strategy
of the drug cartels he admitted it in
the United States sentence Senate
well
we made a commitment to secure our
border and you heard about Jim's bill
this morning at 3 A.M the members the
Republican members of the committee of
Homeland Security Michael guess is my
vice chair and so many others
culminated the work of several months of
stubby pencil back room work figuring
out just the language that would get the
job done
and deliver for the American people when
we did that
and there are many aspects of this bill
we took the money that hasn't been spent
we're going to build 900 miles a wall
we're going to clear uh Cedar and and
trees O'Kane it's blocking the view of
border patrol we're going to take care
of those border patrol agents 17
suicides
in a force of 17
000 because they're overwhelmed with
this open border
Mr Biden care no
and care they even made fun of them
and denigrated them knowing full well
that those men weren't whipping those
migrants we have the proof now by the
way
there are many other aspects technology
license plate readers authorizations for
the border patrol to do things they need
to do to do their job and it has been an
honor to work with the members of this
committee I owe it to every single
member we owe it to every single member
of this committee for doing the hard
work that they've done and uh it's been
an honor to work with them and get that
bill done and if I seem a bit pressured
it's because we were up till 3am getting
it done oh yeah but right there with
chairman uh McCall who is with us also
I'd like to turn it over to my vice
chair and a great American from
Mississippi Mr guest
make no mistake
our border is broken
this Administration has been unwilling
or unable to secure the Southwest border
statistics show
FY 21 under President Biden we set a
record of 1.9 million encounters
along our border last year FY 22
we shattered that record with more than
2.7 million encounters along the
Southwest border
and now in FY 23 we are expected to
break that once again with the number
that is projected to exceed over 3
million and that number is projected
before title 42
expires two weeks from today
additionally we know that drugs smuggled
across our borders
are killing young people at an alarming
rate
and our border patrol agents are
experiencing a crisis of morale
secretary mayorkas as chairman Greene
spoke of moments ago continues to deny
the crisis that exists on our border
even as his chief of Patrol recently
testified before Congress that five of
the nine sectors along the Southwest
border were not secure
House Republicans are stepping in to
fill that Gap that gap of leadership
created by the inactions of this
Administration
this legislation were hired thousands of
new agents
it will pay retention bonus to Front
Line officers
we will invest in new technology
we will construct hundreds of miles of
walls and barriers
and we will support our local and our
state partners
the time to act is now
and Republicans must lead this fight
the fight to secure our border
the fight to support the hard-working
men and women of law enforcement
and the fight to stop the flow of
illegal drugs into coming into our
communities that are killing Young
Americans
I promise you I pledge to you as
Republicans we will not back down from
this fight that we will bring this
legislation to the floor and that we
will combat the failures of the Biden
Administration
at this time I would like to introduce
to you my friend from the great state of
Texas the chairman of Foreign Affairs
chairman McCall
uh thanks leader uh Jim great work on
Judiciary and uh we're up till what
three four o'clock in the morning
good work
good morning
um yeah like I I you know speak uh
plain talk I've dealt with this issue
for 20 years in Congress
prior to that I was a federal prosecutor
I had the as U.S attorney the Border in
my district
um my first bill 20 years ago was to end
catch and release
and here we are 20 years later
same policy
um I know this border well because my
state of Texas Bears the burden
my state has appropriated 4.5 billion
dollars just this session
to deal with a federal government issue
it's not a state issue
it's a responsibility the federal
government and they have
completely the federal government
has completely failed as I told my orcas
you sir you have failed in your job
interestingly when he went down to the
border the border patrol agents turned
their backs on him
because
by what they said he turned his back on
them
the morale has never been worse
I've seen this movie so many times
and I've tried to fix it so many times
and we have a fix to it
but this is the worst I've ever seen it
On the Border it is wide open and why
because the first thing the Biden
Administration did
with a stroke of a pen
was to rescind
remain in Mexico
to rescind the migrant protection
protocols which were working
what that meant was
if you come into the United States
you'll have to remain in Mexico pending
your political Asylum claim 15 percent
are Justified 85 percent are usually not
but what did that do it it sent a
message it sent a message to the cartels
it sent a message to the cartels that
we're not open for business anymore
and what Biden did by rescinding remain
in Mexico sent a message to the cartels
open for business come on in
five million people encounters
what are we going to do with 5 million
people a hundred thousand deaths due to
fentanyls
my oldest daughter's been to five
funerals my son went to one just last
Sunday
it's killing
young people in America it's dangerous
criminals coming in people on the
terrorist watch was for God's sakes
this is irresponsible
and we need to fix it and you know what
as I said
last night on our committee mark this
should not be a partisan issue
this should be an American issue
protecting the sovereignty of the United
States and our borders from the threats
that we see my bill out of the Foreign
Affairs committee will reinstate remain
in Mexico
it will reinstate the migrant protection
protocols and the Asylum claim laws with
Central America so we can shut this
thing down
shut it down this is the root cause of
the entire crisis
so I want to thank the leaders you know
leader this leader
Mr guest this guy you know
three o'clock in the morning thank you
this is an answer a solution
it should be bipartisan it's sad it's
not
I told Benny Thompson that last night
Why Can't This Be bipartisan we used to
do that
we used to do that
but this is going to be the Republican
solution to the problem thank you
but that will be happy to take some
questions yeah
well our members have been very
interested in having us bring a border
security package to the floor since we
ran on this last year and especially
since we took the majority obviously our
members want to know what the final
product is and so we've been working for
months to put that together and as you
can see it's gone through three
different committees it's a number of
bills that have gone through those
committees so now that we have all the
bills out we're going to get that
information to our members I'm very
confident we're going to pass it when we
return in May and again let's challenge
the president and the Senate to not only
acknowledge this problem but to join
with us and actually doing something
about this problem instead of sitting
back and letting 300 young people die
every single day and they don't care
uh can you talk about uh the issue of
Asylum specifically that was the
sticking point when um earlier versions
of the bill came out we wanted
two weeks of Congress and that led you
know with the oxygen there that led to
you you all went back to drawing board
how did you uh find agreement there or
they're still sticking yeah we had a lot
of meetings with our members that are
most interested in the details of this
both on the committee and off I'm asked
chairman Jordan to come up and talk
about it but I was in all of those
meetings and watched people like chip
Roy Mario Diaz ball art Carlos Jimenez
Tony Gonzalez Tom McClintock all coming
together and figuring this out and
saying how do we address this problem we
understand why Asylum is there the
Asylum process was being completely
abused and ignored and so if we make the
Asylum process work again we really want
to do is take away the magnet that is
encouraging people to come here
illegally that don't have valid Asylum
claims that's what Joe Biden did that's
we fixing this bill Jim can get into the
details well I would just add we want
quicker adjudication as the leader
talked about of those Asylum claims and
the legitimate ones that Mr McCall
referenced truly still you know eligible
for Asylum we want them to get that in a
faster time frame so what our
legislation says is you come to the
Border you file your Asylum claim if we
have space to for detention we will
detain people while that's being
evaluated we we think that'll move it
quicker and if not then there will be
returned to their home as they await
their their claim that makes sense
that's consistent with the MPP policy
that was in place in the prior
Administration the language that then Mr
McCall's bill
um and as the leader pointed out we had
Broad
discussions uh across the conference and
we think we arrived at something that is
going to help everybody and get 218
votes
yes sir so as the language between these
packages is any good going into your
resolved before it's combining
if we could package it all together if
you watch what we did with the lower
energy cost act it's it's probably a
good model for how we're handling this
there were almost 20 different bills on
on what ultimately became hr1 so what we
did is take all the different pieces
that came out of multiple committees all
dealing with lowering energy costs and
then put them into one package hr1 you
know and you put them in different
titles based on which piece they're
addressing of that here in this case all
fall under the category of border
security but three different committees
with a number of different bills
addressing all of these different
problems and so we'll pull them all
together into one piece of legislation
yes ma'am
in fact I talked to Daniel house again
this morning about that we're continuing
to have conversations with our members
you know a lot of members have been
watching how all the pieces have been
coming together and again those who are
the most passionate about this that have
some of their own ideas have been
working with us coming into some of
these meetings and then ultimately you
work through those issues and then we'll
bring the package to the floor
yeah do you plan on having a lot of
communication with the Administration or
red state senators so that this should I
say red State Democrat senators in order
to get this passed so it tells me
they're going to be hearing about it
from their constituents we all have been
heeding the calls from all of our
constituents this is not just an issue
that involves border state members as
we've seen and pointed out for over a
year and a half now because of what Joe
Biden did to open up our border and not
just create this crisis in States like
Texas but then to have other groups
literally at dark of night shipping
people to every state in America every
state is now a border state and we don't
know how bad the problem is because
they're hiding these facts from the
American people every one of you should
be asking the White House will you give
us a number of how many people have come
across illegally and where have you sent
them they're being sent somewhere in
many cases and it's been reported at
dark of night you know they were having
a Committee hearing until three o'clock
in the morning every night our border
security is at the border at three
o'clock in the morning and every other
hour but then they put them on buses on
trains on planes and nobody knows where
they go and so ever every every elected
officials heard about this problem the
problem is some of those elected
officials have put their head in the
sand for far too long they're not going
to be able to hide from this anymore
because there will be a vote on the
house floor where every member of
Congress Republican Democrat will have
to take a side are you going to side
with people who are sick and tired of
watching 300 young people die every
single day are you going to do something
about it like we are and shame on them
if they hide from this problem any
longer
you talked a lot about it new
Investments that you make
them how would you pay for that under
the spending ability yesterday
and then second
as a way of trying to get this bill
bill
well first of all on the funding the
Border all the different entities under
Homeland Security have all the money
they need to solve this problem what
they've done is taken specific action to
make the problem worse and then it
becomes more expensive when President
Biden says the borders open by getting
rid of remaining Mexico by stopping
construction of the wall and we went to
some of these sites I remember one of
the first border trips I took after
President Biden created this problem
they took us the border patrol agents we
got to embed with the border patrol
agents so you see just how bad it is and
why and they took us to one of the
abandoned work sites so President Biden
was paying the construction company that
was tasked with building the wall he was
paying them not to build the wall it's
sort of what he did paying people not to
work it's actually more expensive to do
that because then you don't get the
economic benefit of the money you're
spending so you're spending money to not
do something that would have actually
saved the taxpayers money by making the
Border process work prop properly and
secure in the Border we will save
billions of taxpayer dollars and it's a
long time coming I know it went through
your committee if you want to touch on
that yeah so we did cut go which is our
commitment to America too right when we
built the rules of how this house would
operate so if you look at the back of
the bill there are very specific
programs listed to cut to cover where we
increase the money so for example the
the bonus that's going to go to the uh
the retention bonus that's going to go
to the border patrol guys nine thousand
dollars roughly per agent uh that's a
hundred million dollars you can see
where we take that money from in there
it's a it's a minimal amount but it it
the the cuts are at the bottom of the
bill and the uh and the plus-ups are in
those Personnel numbers
part of that proposal is to
to create more processing centers and
control
do you think that would in any way
produce the volume of migrants coming to
the U.S border what President Biden and
secretary mayorkas are doing are
doubling down on the failed policies
that created this problem rather than
working with us to solve the problem
again we have the most generous the most
generous immigration system in the in
the world America lets in over a million
people a year legally into our country
it's part of the American dream story
that we all tell so many of us are
families of immigrants
and there is a legal process to come
here and I think that's what the
president forgets about is that people
want to get back to the legal process so
this idea that you just create more
opportunities for people to come here
illegally and then look the other way
that's what created the dreamer problem
that's what created this new problem is
that they're encouraging people to come
into America legally knowing they don't
have valid Asylum claims they don't have
beds to house them there's no mechanism
when they send them to other states to
take care of those folks they don't care
about those people
they're just bringing them here for some
political agenda and then they don't
care what happens to them after but they
have no plan
for them what we're saying is like let's
get back to the legal system
that should be working for everybody
everybody should know what the rules are
to come to America just like any other
country
other countries have limits on how many
people come into their Nations and their
numbers are a lot lower than ours Name a
nation that's close to us over a million
people a year we let in Legally every
year the more you incentivize people the
more you incentivize people the bigger
the wave will be and all the processing
Centers do is provide more incentive oh
the door's even more open all I got to
do is get a coyote from the drug cartel
to fill out my CBP one app for me I'm
sure they're paying another little extra
fee to get that done every single thing
Alejandro mayarkas is doing is to speed
more people into this country you take a
look at his budget it's intentional they
cut CBP and put billions more into a
contingency fund to bring more people
into the country this is intentional and
the drug cartels are seizing the day to
get more fentanyl in here and make more
money and you ask the parents of that
little baby how many of you have
children was crawling around on the
floor of a VRBO in Florida the tenant
before had fentanyl a little baby was
dead every single American is at risk
for these ridiculous Open Door policies
well we've had enough and these bills
and the men that have done and men and
women who've done the work to put this
together are saying no more and I do
want to make this point before the final
question
because we haven't talked about this yet
today we've talked about this in other
settings and I think all of you know
this however much it gets covered it's
not enough what President Biden has done
to open up the southern border has
created a multi-billion dollar industry
for the drug cartels of Mexico President
Biden is providing billions of dollars
to the drug cartels in Mexico who now
have operational control over our
Southern border every American ought to
be outraged about that and by the way
most are and not only are they getting a
multi-billion dollar windfall the drug
cartels what they're doing to these
young kids we've seen it the rapes the
human trafficking
not only the deaths 300 deaths a day
should be enough but all of the other
things that they're doing to these young
kids are bringing across as they're
making billions of dollars off of the
track trafficking is disgusting Joe
Biden ought to be disgusted about it the
thing is Joe Biden can do something
about it he created this problem he
needs to work with us to solve this
problem last question
or forced out somehow does house
leadership have a position on that what
we have said is all options need to be
on the table but we need to get the
facts out and these committees have been
doing a great job of getting the facts
out as they've been writing these pieces
of legislation that are critically
important so we've been working on two
fronts one is legislating
which is a very critical piece of our
job in the majority but the other is the
oversight and accountability part and
the good news is all of these committees
have been doing both they've been having
hearings to get more facts and let's let
the facts lead where they may
we haven't Limited in any way what they
can go and find out or what happens once
we find out all the facts but we're also
taking the lead to legislate to fix this
problem and if the people that are there
aren't fixing it which they're not
secretary mayorkas has said over and
over again the border secure Joe Biden
has said The Border's secure Kamala
Harris has said The Border's secure
every American knows the borders not
secure
and so it's about time they start
shooting straight with the American
people but we're not going to sit back
and try to play that charade they are
we're actually working to fix this
problem as we hold people accountable
who have created this crisis that
Americans are facing every single day
thank you all and we'll see you on the
floor in two weeks on this bill
thank you
every time